you know I just I just want to reiterate
that she's got to learn how to trust in
herself and that's not an easy thing to
do how do you do that how do you how do
you better trust in you I know how I do
it but but yeah I think for me it's I've
learned to trust myself in the decisions
because I have used that process that I
have given Kat is I will take at any
major decision or even you know minor
decisions if it's something that I'm
wavering on and I'm unsure about like
yes I know that I'm thirsty I'm gonna
have a glass of water that's a pretty
easy decision but but you know given
those harder decisions where we kind of
get paralyzed when they're major life
decisions I'd look at all of the factors
involved whether it's Mariah whether
it's you whether it's the time that I
get to spend with my family the the all
my resources that it affects not just my
money but yes my time my attention like
how was that decision going to affect
those once I take all that into
consideration I can have an informed
decision there's still risk there's
still a possibility that I might be
making the wrong decision but after
applying that formula for years and
years and years I've learned to gain
trust in myself and Kat I still screw it
up this has to be like I still make bad
decisions but I make less bad decisions
I'd make way less bad decisions today
than what I did you know my 25 year old
self yes so it sounds to me like what
what you're getting at there is you have
to make some decisions and I think to
set yourself up for success is make some
relatively easy decisions that you know
okay I have a 90% chance this is the
right decision now ten percent of the
time you're gonna fail I mean you make
ten decisions one of them is gonna be a
failure so you are gonna fail but you're
going to set yourself up for okay now
that I'm making more decisions I'm
leaning into it I'm no longer paralyzed
by indecision I am empowered by my
decisiveness I'm going to be willing to
quickly make these decisions especially
for the benign one so we just went in
the essay what are the benign decisions
where there's essentially no consequence
right now for the big decisions it does
make sense
it's a way if you want to buy a house
you don't want to do that overnight
right that's it's a big process right
you want to go skydiving you really want
to think about that because you could
die right if if you want to quit your
job it's just like well I'm feel like
whit
today I might as well just walk into my
boss's office today and say screw you I
quit I'm leaving right now
that's there are consequences for that
but for most of the decisions we make
every single day we're treating it like
it's life or death whether it's not life
or death at all make those decisions
make them often and the more you make
those decisions
the more you'll be able to trust
yourself yeah so so your formula for
trusting yourself is just to continue to
make decisions yes and either learn from
the mistakes or you've learned to trust
yourself because you've made really good
decisions yeah the only thing I would
add to that is make more benign
decisions hmm and and because what are
you doing is you're building up that
muscle so that becomes easier when the
difficult decisions come around and you
trust yourself more now because you know
your ratio has improved maybe it's just
60/40 at first and you're making 60%
good decision 40% bad but over time
that'll change 70/30 80/20 yeah no a
sudden now a big decision comes along
you're like oh I can trust myself now
because I know most of the time I'm
making a good decision all of a sudden
you start making those good decisions
the worrying starts to dissipate I've
got two more things for katkat cut out
as many decisions as you can in your
life start wearing one outfit a day
stop try stop deciding where you're
wearing in the morning know what you're
gonna want necessary decision necessary
decisions cut out as many unnecessary
decisions as possible the other thing
too is on those big decisions go consult
someone go find a close friend confidant
family member mentor someone like this
this apartment hunting that I've been
going through there are five different
people I talk to about about about the
apartment that Mariah and I are going to
move into and it's because I need as
much information as possible to make the
most informed decision possible at the
same time don't let them make the
decision for course not and I think
that's important because we can't we
can't abdicate our own responsibility so
it's good to get to get other people's
input their feedback that you trust so
do not let them because then you're
actually losing your own decision oh
yeah well yeah and a lot of people put
it on someone else so they can be like
oh well that was your decision right
it's still your own fault for going on
their decisions ya realize that no
matter what decision you make it is
going to be your decision even if
someone else influenced you so you they
don't have to live with it either so
your trusted
confidence it really has to live at that
decision and so ultimately you're the
person who's gonna be living in your
home or getting rid of that old cardigan
or whatever it might be you have to
determine is this decision right for me
now is it right for Ryan or Shawn or
Jordan or anyone else is it right for me
given my own circumstances
you